this video we're going to talk about how
to solve linear equations involving
three variables and three equations
using the elimination method so we're
going to go through these two problems
number one here and number two here you
might want to take a screenshot or write
these down and try and solve them on
your own and we'll go through them
together
okay this first problem you can see
we've got
three variables three equations we're
going to use the elimination method but
first we have to pick a variable that we
want to eliminate so you want to
eliminate the x's first the y's first or
the z's first you want to try to pick
one that's easiest but it doesn't really
matter ultimately which one you pick but
you want to stick with that variable so
what i mean by that i'm going to show
you let's take equation number two here
and number three here and let's go ahead
and add those together and the reason
i'm adding those together is that you
can see
that this positive y and this negative y
when we add straight down those are
going to cancel one another out
effectively eliminating the
y variable so let's go ahead and do that
we're going to get 4x we're going to get
negative z
and we're going to get 2. now we use the
second and third equations here but we
need to also use that first equation as
well sometimes students go on to trying
to eliminate a different variable after
that but you want to stick with that y
variable and you want to make sure you
use all three equations now what you can
do is you can either combine the first
equation with the second or the first
with the third but we definitely have to
use that first equation so what i'm
going to do here is i'm going to use the
first equation
and the second equation
now again if you're doing this on your
own there's more than one way to solve
these problems but at the end you're
going to get the exact same answer so
you can check that in just a moment so
we're sticking with the y's but you can
see here what i need to do because i
have a negative 3y here and a positive
1y here that i actually need to get that
second equation there to be a positive
3y so that when i add straight down
those y's are going to cancel one
another out so i'm going to multiply
that whole equation by 3 which is going
to give us 3x
plus 3y
minus 6z equals negative 18. i'm just
going to draw a line through that and
i'm going to add these two equations
together to eliminate the y's so that's
going to give us
5x the y's cancel we get minus 5z
and equals negative 5. so now you can
see we're down to
two equations involving two variables x
and z we're going to work with those two
equations now and you're probably
familiar with this from algebra one
but let's go ahead and eliminate one of
the variables here let's go ahead and
eliminate the z's and you can see here
that i've got a negative 5z
and in this top equation i have a
negative 1z so in order to get those
these to cancel out what i'm going to do
is i'm going to multiply this equation
by negative 5. and if i do that let me
put the result up here we're going to
get
negative 20x
positive 5z
equals negative 10. and then this bottom
equation i'm just going to bring it over
here 5x
minus 5z equals negative 5 and i'm going
to add straight down so that those
z's are going to cancel out so we're
left with negative 15x equals negative
15
and if we divide by negative 15 to both
sides you can see that x is coming out
to 1.
so now we want to do we went from three
variables three equations to two
variables two equations down to one
variable one equation we wanna now start
back substituting this x equals one
either into
this equation for x
or this equation for x
and we want to solve for z i'm going to
do the top equation i'm going to say 4
times 1
minus z equals 2
so that's 4 minus z equals 2. subtract 4
from both sides that's going to give us
negative 2 and divide by negative 1 you
can see that z is equal to 2.
so now we know what x and z are we need
to solve for y i'm going to go back to
these
original equations here okay with the
three variables three equations and you
can put it into any one of these three
equations but i'm going to put it into
this middle equation because you can see
here we just have 1y it's going to be a
little bit easier to solve for that
1y
so let's go ahead and do that so we have
uh x which is one
y we don't know
and two times z two times two okay
equals negative six
so if we solve that let's see we've got
one plus y minus 4 equals negative 6.
y minus 3 equals negative 6 and if we
add 3 to both sides you can see that
we're going to get y equals negative 3.
now when you write your final answer you
want to write it as a triple
x y z alphabetical order and so in this
case it would be x equals one y equals
negative three and z is equal to two
and that is your final result for
example number two
we're able to solve this one on your own
so again it's that same process of
picking a variable and sticking with it
and you're trying to use the elimination
method to cancel out either the x's the
y's or the z's now in this problem i
think what i'm going to do is i'm going
to work with the z's so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take that first
equation and that third equation
and i'm going to add them together
because you can see that
negative z here in the top equation
positive z in that third equation when
you add them together they're going to
cancel one another out
so if i do that let's see we're going to
get x and negative 2x which is negative
1x
y plus 2y is 3y the z's we said they
cancel and 9 plus negative 9 is 0.
okay great so now we've used the first
and third we need to use that second
equation and we also need to stick with
eliminating the z's so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to
let me go ahead and write these down
over here so we've got x plus y minus z
equals 9.
and we've got 3x minus y plus 4z equals
negative 12. now we said we were going
to stick with the z's here but you can
see that we've got 4z in the bottom
equation
negative 1z in the top equation it would
be a lot better if that top equation was
negative 4z because then we could just
add straight down and eliminate the z so
what we're going to do is we're going to
multiply that top equation by 4 make
sure you do it to the entire equation so
that's going to give us 4x plus 4y
minus 4z equals 36.
now you can see when we add straight
down
7x
plus 3y the z's cancel and we get
24. okay so you can see we're down to
two variables
two equations and we can solve that
system which you're probably familiar
with from algebra one again we have to
pick a variable to eliminate i think i'm
going to pick the y's because you can
see this is 3y this is 3y all i would
have to do is multiply one of these
equations by negative 1.
and so that's going to give us positive
x negative 3y equals 0. make sure you
multiply the whole equation by negative
1. and if i bring down this equation
other equation here you can see that
when i add straight down the y's now are
going to
cancel one another out and we get 8x
equals 24 divide by 8 and you can see
we're getting x equals 3. so now we went
from three variables three equations
down to
two variables two equations and now
we're down to one variable one equation
so now we have to make our way back up
that ladder
and
take the x equals 3 and plug it into one
of the two variable equations so either
here
or here for x i'll just go ahead and do
uh the one on the left there so we're
going to do negative
3 plus 3y equals 0. add 3 to both sides
divide by 3 and you can see y equals 1.
so now we've got x and y we need to
solve for z
again you can go back to
these original equations with three
variables you can use any one of the
equations i think i'm going to just use
the bottom equation and the reason i'm
picking that one i think it's going to
be a little bit easier because you just
have one z there so you won't have to
divide at the end but really it doesn't
matter you can pick any one
so let's go ahead and do that bottom one
so we have negative two times x which is
three
plus two times y which is one plus z we
don't know equals negative nine
so we're getting negative six plus two
plus z equals negative nine and then
let's see if simplifying negative four
plus z equals negative nine add four to
both sides and you can see that we're
getting z is equal to
negative five
and if we write this again in
alphabetical order x y z we're getting 3
1
negative 5. now you can check your work
by taking that 3 1 and negative 5 and
putting it into the first equation you
should get 9 the second equation should
get negative 12 third equations should
get negative 9 and it's a way of just
checking and verifying that makes all
the equations true you know you've got
the correct answer
so this wraps up how to solve linear
equations in three variables
if you want to see more examples i'll
put a
another video that you can watch that i
did on the screen and if you want to
dive more into these algebra 2 type
concepts i've got an algebra 2 video
course also covering all of algebra 2 or
college algebra type topics you can
check out that course as well i'll see
you in the next video